There was a time when comic book movies were
seen as a joke or a poisoned chalice to an
actor's career. Not any more.
These days, the comic book movie genre is
one of the most popular in Hollywood - heck,
five of the twenty highest-grossing movies
of all time are comic book movies - and popular,
talented actors appearing in the genre is
the norm.
But not every actor has yet been given the
chance to play a live action superhero. Many
of those unfortunate souls have expressed
a public interest in playing a specific one,
however - and that's what this video is about.
Watch it, enjoy it, and don't forget to subscribe
to our channel to regularly see more like
it.
Here are ten popular actors who want to be
a Marvel or DC superhero.
Norman Reedus
The Walking Dead's Daryl Dixon - Norman Reedus
- is one of the coolest actors on television
at the moment, so it would be awesome to see
him playing a superhero. Thankfully, the former
model has expressed an interest in playing
Ghost Rider on the big screen!
He rides a motorcycle on The Walking Dead
and explores motorcycle culture in his "Ride
with Norman Reedus" show, and when he was
asked if he'd like to play Ghost Rider in
a movie reboot, Reedus replied enthusiastically
by saying "Hell yeah! It would be a blast.
Do I get a skull face that’s on fire and
all that stuff? F**k yeah. I’m down!"
Bryce Dallas Howard
Bryce Dallas Howard - who has, of course,
already appeared in a superhero movie when
she portrayed Gwen Stacy in 2007's Spider-Man
3 - expressed an interest in a certain titular
Marvel Cinematic Universe role, prior to it
being given to someone else.
That role was Captain Marvel - who will now
be played by Brie Larson, of course. When
asked if she would be interested in the role
at a Jurassic World press day, Howard replied
"Oh my God, will you write that? Will you
write that please? Yes, let’s start a campaign
now. That would be rad." Maybe she'll get
her chance to play a different Marvel heroine
in the future.
Ronda Rousey
Someone with... a little.... yeah let's go
with "a little" less acting talent than Bryce
Dallas Howard also wanted to be Captain Marvel
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe - and that
person was Ronda Rousey. The former UFC champion
first shared her interest in the part during
a Reddit AMA, then posted some fan art of
herself as the character on her Instagram
account.
As previously stated, the role ultimately
went to Brie Larson - even though Marvel Studios
head honcho Kevin Feige actually championed
Rousey for the role - but, given that her
MMA career looks to be over, Rousey will probably
turn to acting on a more full-time basis,
so maybe another opportunity in the comic
book genre will emerge for her in the coming
years.
Daniel Radcliffe
Having played Harry Potter for ten years,
Daniel Radcliffe certainly knows what it's
like to play a heroic character, but there's
no way anyone could describe Potter as a "superhero."
With that in mind, it's no surprise that the
young actor wants to jump on the comic book
movie bandwagon.
Back in 2014, prior to Batman's first appearance
in the DC Extended Universe, Radcliffe was
asked which other big movie franchise he'd
like to appear in. His response? "Batman!
If they reboot that again, I’ll do that,
too. It’s happening isn’t it? With Ben
Affleck. I could be Robin. I’m perfect."
Ryan Potter
From one Potter to another now, but this time
it's Ryan Potter, the actor and martial artist
who is perhaps best-known for providing the
voice of another superhero - Hiro Hamada in
Big Hero 6. Coincidentally, this Potter also
wants to portray Batman's sidekick, Robin
- but his casting would come with a twist.
Potter's father is Japanese, so casting him
as Robin would have to see a change in the
traditional white ethnicity associated with
the character. He wants to play the character
so badly that he made an audition video for
Ben Affleck to show him exactly what he can
offer - a level of enthusiasm that suggests
the ethnicity issue should be completely overlooked!
Anna Kendrick
Being Batman's sidekick seems to be a popular
choice for actors - and not just actors of
the male variety - as Pitch Perfect star Anna
Kendrick also humorously stated she'd like
to play Robin. While sat next to Ben Affleck,
participating in a comedic MTV interview/sketch
about their movie The Accountant, Kendrick
made her pitch for the role.
The actress suddenly appeared dressed in a
Hamburglar costume with an "R" on the front,
having announced that she had a hole in her
schedule that could be filled with a superhero
flick. On a more serious note, there has actually
been a genuine push for Kendrick to play the
character - not least by Deathstroke himself,
Joe Manganiello.
Tyrese Gibson
You'd think that the terrible reception to
2011's Green Lantern movie would have put
actors off appearing as Green Lanterns in
future DC offerings, but that's not actually
the case at all. In fact, Fast and Furious
star Tyrese Gibson has been campaigning quite
actively for the role - to the extent that
he earned himself some meetings to discuss
the possibility of playing John Stewart.
A snippet from one of the many quotes Gibson
has said on the matter is as follows: "I’ve
already had a couple of meetings at Warner
Bros., so we’ll see what happens. I do believe
that there needs to be more black superheroes
out there, but that’s not even my motivation.
I think I would be the best Green Lantern."
Keanu Reeves
Okay, some people might say that Keanu Reeves
has already played a superhero, but the fact
is John Constantine is the epitome of an anti-hero.
Reeves has, however, stated that there are
some more well-known heroic characters that
he'd like to play - those being Batman and
Wolverine.
Within a few moments of the same discussion,
Reeves said "I always wanted to play Wolverine.
But I didn't get that. And they have a great
Wolverine now" and "I always wanted to play
The Dark Knight. But I didn't get that one.
They've had some great Batmans. So now I'm
just enjoying them as an audience." Make your
mind up, Keanu!
Derek Theler
The least-known actor on this list is Derek
Theler. The star of TV's Baby Daddy is a huge
superhero fan and actually auditioned for
the role of Captain America in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe back in 2009 (and he's
also said he'd like to play Thor), but he's
now campaigning to play a DC character - a
certain Shazam!
He frequently shares fan art of himself playing
Shazam on social media, and often captions
the images with how it's his dream to play
the character, as well as with compliments
directed towards The Rock - who is, of course,
playing Black Adam in the DC Extended Universe.
Megan Fox
Believe it or not, Megan Fox is something
of a comic book aficionado and is very keen
to play a superhero on screen - specifically,
one from quite an obscure title - DC's Gen¹³.
Fox said "There’s a comic book called Gen¹³
that they need to make into a movie. There
are three female ass-kicking superheroes.
That’s an opportunity to put three super-hot,
awesome badass girls in a movie, and I imagine
it would be so lucrative."
Fox wasn't, however, remotely interested in
playing Wonder Woman in the DC Extended Universe
(who, of course, is now played by Gal Gadot).
In fact, she totally dissed the character
and the idea of playing her, saying "Wonder
Woman is a lame superhero. She flies around
in her invisible jet and her weaponry is a
lasso that makes you tell the truth. I just
don’t get it. Somebody has a big challenge
on their hands whoever takes that role, but
I don’t want to do it."
Thanks for watching our video about ten popular
actors who want to be a Marvel or DC superhero.
Can you think of any other actors who'd love
to star in Marvel or DC movies? Have your
say in the comments section below and be sure
to subscribe to our channel for more great
videos like this one.